Outback Steakhouse.
Aussie Rules.
ANNIVERSARY OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
STILL THE NEVER ENDING
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION GRINDS
ON.
STEVE BANNON WAS JUST
SUBPOENAED TO APPEAR BEFORE
A SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT
MUELLER'S GRAND JURY.
HE ALSO TESTIFIED TODAY
BEFORE THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE.
BANNON REFUSED TO ANSWER THE
THAT PROMPTED COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO SUBPOENA HIM ON
THE SPOT.
CONGRESSMAN TREY GOWDY OF
SOUTH CAROLINA WAS THERE AND
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
CONGRESSMAN, THANKS FOR
COMING ON.
>> YES, SIR.
THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: DID BANNON ADMIT
BEING A RUSSIAN AGENT?
DID WHAT DID WE LEARN?
>> WE LEARNED ABOUT A NEW
PRIVILEGE THAT BEFORE TODAY
DID NOT EXIST.
IT'S EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE
WORKING IT HE WHITE HOUSE
AND COMMUNICATIONS AFTER YOU
SEPARATE FROM SERVICE AT THE
MOST TORTURED ANALYSIS OF
SO, WHEN YOU MAKE VERY
PROVOCATIVE CLAIMS LIKE
TREASON AND UNPATRIOTIC AND
THERE IS ZERO PERCENT CHANCE
THAT THESE RUSSIAN LAWYERS
WEREN'T WALKED UP TO SEE
CANDIDATE TRUMP THEN YOU ARE
GOING TO BE ASKED ABOUT IT.
AND YOU ARE GOING TO BE
ASKED A LOT ABOUT IT AND
THAT'S WHAT WE TRIED TO DO
TODAY.
>> Tucker: DOES ANYONE
BELIEVE THOSE CLAIMS ARE
TRUE?
I'M SORT OF LOSING TRACK OF
THE POINT OF THIS WHOLE
EXERCISE.
THINK THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
COLLUDED WITH THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT IN ORDER TO
SUBVERT OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> I CAN'T SPEAK FOR MY
FRIENDS ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE AISLE.
ADAM SCHIFF SAID HE HAD
I HAVE SEEN NO EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION BETWEEN THE
RUSSIANS AND PRESIDENT
TRUMP, BETWEEN THE RUSSIANS
AND THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
BUT IT WAS STEVE BANNON WHO
USED THE WORD TREASONOUS AND
STEVE BANNON USED THE WORD
UNPATRIOTIC.
THOSE ARE TWO SERIOUS
ACCUSATIONS TO LEVEL
PARTICULARLY AT THE
PRESIDENT'S SON.
SO YOU ARE GOING TO BE ASKED
ABOUT IT AND HE ALSO NEEDED
TO BE ASKED ABOUT THINGS
THAT HAPPENED WITH RESPECT
TO COMEY.
THE REASON WE HAD A LITTLE
HICCUP THIS MORNING IS
BECAUSE EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE
NOW COVERS THINGS BEFORE YOU
BECOME THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
WHICH IS JUST MIND-NUMBING
AND THERE IS NO LEGAL
SUPPORT FOR IT BUT WE CAN'T
MAKE A WITNESS ANSWER A
QUESTION.
DEMOCRATS DRAG DRAGGING THIS
OUT AS LONG AS THEY POSSIBLY
CAN AND THEY WERE REALLY
REALLY LET ISN'T A TO START.
SO ONCE YOU ARE LET ISN'T A
THEY WANT THIS TO DRAG
THROUGH THE 2018 ELECTIONS.
THEY WANT TO RETAKE THE
HOUSE.
IT IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
CONDUCT AS THOROUGH AN
INVESTIGATION AS WE CAN BUT
ALSO DO IT IN THE MOST
EXPEDITED WAY THAT WE CAN IT
WOULD BE REALLY HELPFUL IF
THE DEMOCRATS WANTED TO GET
STARTED A LITTLE SOONER.
LIKE IN MARCH OR APRIL OF
THIS YEAR.
BUT THEY DIDN'T.
DON'T THINK ANY OF YOUR
VIEWERS ARE HOLDING THEIR
BREATH WAITING ON WHAT A
CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATION
UNCOVERS.
I THINK THEY ARE WAITING ON
CREDENCE THAN OURS DOES.
>> Tucker: THE WHOLE THING
SEEMS SO STUPID TO ME.
I'M WILLING TO BELIEVE
WRONGDOING ON A LOT OF
LEVELS BY A LOT OF PEOPLE
BUT RUSSIAN COLLUSION SEEMS
UNPROVEN.
I WONDER JUST HYPOTHETICALLY
IF ROLES WERE REVERSED AND
DEMOCRATS HELD ALL THE
LEVERS OF POWER DO YOU THINK
REPUBLICANS WOULD BE ABLE TO
DO WHAT DEMOCRATS HAVE DONE,
WHICH IS DRIVE THIS
INVESTIGATION FROM THE
BEGINNING?
>> NO.
I CAN TELL YOU FIRSTHAND WE
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO DO THAT
AN IMPOSSIBLE TIME GETTING
ACCESS TO DOCUMENTS AND
BUT THE BIGGEST HEAD WIND OF
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA COULD
GIVE A DAMN LESS ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED IN BENGHAZI.
THEY ARE REALLY REALLY
INTERESTED IN WHAT HAPPENED
IN RUSSIA, IN PART BECAUSE
THEY DON'T KNOW ANYBODY THAT
VOTED FOR DONALD TRUMP.
SO, THEY ARE STILL TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW THIS ELECTION
OCCURRED AND HOW HIS
ELECTION OCCURRED SO THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA IS THE
BIGGEST DIFFERENCE TO ME
BETWEEN INVESTIGATION I DID
A COUPLE YEARS AGO AND THE
ONE WE ARE DOING NOW.